Okay, so we have this ConvolutionCyclopeptideSequencing algorithm, and
it works really well on the hypothetical
spectra that we've considered.
But these spectra aren't necessarily
representative of spectra that we might
encounter in practice.
In particular, we had 25% false and
missing masses,
and that's much less noisy than what we'll
be able to obtain from practical spectra.
Also, I've said that the mass
spectrometer is, we can think
of it as a scale, but it doesn't really
just weigh the peptide fragments;
it's a lot more complicated than that.
What it does is, first it ionizes the
peptide fragments.
So it converts them into ions
with a positive or negative charge, and
then
it sorts these fragments using an
electromagnetic field.
Once it does that, it's then able to not
measure
the mass but the mass/charge ratio of each
fragment.
Then it determines the intensity
(approximately we'll
think about it as the number of ions)
at each mass/charge ratio value.
And so,
after it determines this intensity at each
mass/charge
ratio value, we're able to create a graph
from this.
And so this is really what the spectrum
is.
The spectrum is a graph of intensity on
the Y axis
and the mass/charge ratio on the X
axis.
So it's detecting give or take,
the number of ions at each mass/charge
ratio value.
And from this we somehow need to convert
it into mass, right?
All we have is mass/charge ratio.
We want to consider the most
popular elements in this or
the most intense “peaks” is the term we'll use.
And, the challenge is now to reconstruct,
in this case, to first convert to mass,
and then use those masses to
reconstruct the peptide in a case where we
may not have 25% false and missing masses,
we may have like 2/3 of the masses that
are detected in our spectrum may be false,
in which case we've got to really
switch up what we do,
and we may need to adapt the algorithms
that we have.
And so, on Stepic, this is where we give
you the example
to take a real spectrum and try to process
it, and adapt
the algorithms that you have, maybe come
up with new ideas and
try to sequence a real peptide from a
real experimental spectrum.